new england in the market and the draft
for a quarterback still of course they
might be
question is who's available on that
front and our friend from nfl media
group
uh the better half of move the sticks
podcast bucky brooks here on the rich
ozone show how are you bucky brooks
i'm here rich how's everything i am
better for talking to you
so let's jump into it here um
do you think new england is in the
market for a first round quarterback
which as you know is not
the mo of bill belichick one would think
maybe it's because tom brady
was sitting there for all those years
but do you think that
that that could be actually the new mo
for new england going into this draft
and if so who
bucky uh i think it very much could be
in play
i think obviously it's about value and
if they feel like they can get a
striking distance
to give one of the big four quarterbacks
i think they
absolutely would make that move and what
i mean the big four is
the usual suspects and whatever trevor
lawrence
zach wilson justin fields and trey lance
i think if they can get in range to get
one of those guys
i think they will do it i know there'd
be some discussion about matt jones
i just don't know in terms of how new
england
when they made the decision to run it
back with cam nate newton
i wonder if they're shifting their
offensive philosophy
and maybe they find a young quarterback
who has similar skills
so they can build a new and improved
offensive approach
that allows them to play the way that
they want to play uh which is
take care of the ball run it play great
defense and find a way to win
games by not beating themselves
interesting so the whole you know
um chatter and we all know what
chatter's worth in our business
certainly around this time of year bucky
brooks but
the chatter of well new england uh bill
belichick is tight
with nick saban so he'll be as plugged
in on mac jones as he could possibly be
and that might be
certainly sitting there at 15 a rare
spot for new england to be sitting in
the first round
that might be a good spot for him there
but you're thinking maybe the cam newton
signing will give you an indication as
to
who new england would be looking at in
the draft well i mean i think that's how
they want to play if you go back and
look remember they played a certain
style
for 20 years with tom brady and because
of that we were accustomed to seeing
them have
maybe a statuesque pocket pastor that's
how joshua daniels
and those guys want to play but if you
go back and you really look at
new england and you look at the
quarterbacks that have given them
problems
over the years cam newton desean watson
mobile playmakers because mobile
playmakers allow you to be
imperfect with your personnel you don't
have to have the best offensive line you
may not need to have a level receivers
because the quarterback can make it
right with his athleticism
we've seen the league shift towards a
more athletic player
at that position i believe from a
defensive standpoint belichick
understands the challenge of that maybe
he wants to get into that lane
because he knows what it causes the
headaches that it caused
for defensive play calls around the
league when you have a player that can
do those things from pockets
fascinating bucky brooks here on the
rich eisen show
um so where do you stand on the on the
quarterbacks
currently sitting here after uh what
would have been a combine for
all of us your evaluation so far of this
group would be
what bucky uh in order i would go trevor
lawrence
justin fields zach wilson trade lands
and then matt jones uh with the
separation behind those guys
trevor lawrence i would say is number
one i think everyone kind of understands
who he is i kind of
describe him as justin herbert plus
meaning he has all the things that
justin herbert brings
but maybe even a little more sizzle when
it comes to his own talent and those
things and that's saying a lot based on
how justin harvard played
i think justin field is maybe the
underrated
uh quarterback prospect in this class
because we don't really talk enough
about him we nick picked his game we
talked about
how he didn't play well versus indiana
and northwestern
but when you really look at him play
he's a very talented player
i would say arguably he and trevor
lawrence have always been one and two
from the time they were in high school
i think his talent warrants that kind of
consideration
i think people need to be careful of
making um the evaluation of him based on
the offensive system that he played in
which had a lot of options where he's
waiting on wide receivers to declare
which way they're going before he
releases it he is a very talented player
and i think as we look at josh allen
have success
with the baltimore build i think we need
to have our imagination
in that lane when we think about justin
fields
zach wilson is the guy who has really
come out of nowhere to be at the top of
the charts
zach wilson was the guy who had to win a
quarterback competition prior to last
season
he wins it and then he dazzles at byu
tremendous arm talent great athlete
plays the game the way that you want to
see it played going through reads
and just looking very natural doing it
the one concern would be
he didn't play against a high level of
competition not to any fault of byu's or
his own
they just didn't play a level games and
the one game that they played against
coastal carolina
wasn't his best he had some flashes but
it wasn't his best game so you worry
about that
trey lance who had his pro day today is
outstanding as a prospect
and i think unfortunately for him he
decided to play in a one game showcase
this year
with a team that's not nearly as good as
they've been in the past because
north dakota state got beat this year
after you left
and so we have that stain on our brain
that ah maybe he's not as good as he
thought but if you go back and look at
2019
he's talented he's a dual threat
playmaker 2700
yards over a thousand rushing yards he's
very very talented and so
i think it's a unique class where you
have guys that can do it a bunch of
different ways
and now it's about going to the ice
cream shop and deciding
what flavor do i want today what tickles
my fancy because i think all these guys
have the opportunity to be fantastic
bucky brooks here on the rich eisen show
you're the first uh of this week for
sure
uh to have justin fields above zach
wilson
on their uh quarterback draft depth
chart so i will ask you the question i'm
asking everybody else
with the question of darnold or second
overall selection
on a draft choice uh quarterback
short of desean watson based on our
colleagues and i have jim trotter on an
hour number three uh steve weich and he
on huddle and flow getting something
from david cully that makes us think
that
watson might not be in houston when it's
all said and done
uh barring that what do you think the
jets should do at number two overall
bucky well the sam dawn has been built a
bad hand
um he hasn't had all the weapons that
you would necessarily want to see he
hasn't had maybe
the support that you want from a head
coach but i believe it's in the best
interest of the
jets to hit the reset button at
quarterback
because we've seen the best way to build
a super bowl contender
is to build your team around a
quarterback playing on an original
rookie deal call certainty allows you to
build up the rest of the team
and ultimately the team that wins is the
best team
that's why we've seen in the last 10
super bowls
eight teams that have had quarterbacks
playing on rookie deals
if you take zach wilson or justin fields
one i think you're getting a better
prospect and player than you were
getting with sam donald
i think in the system that they're going
to play which is an extension of the cal
shanahan system
one game play action boots young
quarterbacks should be able to flourish
in that just look at what baker mayfield
was able to do under kevin stefanski
i think by having a young quarterback
eddie on a
really cheap and team friendly deal it
allows you to build up the rest of the
team
and then in two years maybe you have a
team that is a legitimate
contender for a playoff bid because
you've been able to allocate the
resources
evenly around the team as opposed to
having to pick up the fifth year option
and eventually pay sam donald
a big deal when his play hasn't
necessarily won warranted that
justin fields is a jet you think first
night of the draft
that's what you're thinking right uh i
would say justin fields because
i like justin fields as a better player
but if you're asking me who i think the
jets will pick i think they're going to
pick
zach wilson why uh jack wilson for me
because
she's like rich it's tough i just think
justin fields is a better player i think
some like the way that jack feels plays
the game he plays it like
a quarterback should play he goes
through his progression he goes to the
wreath he has tremendous arm talent
he has the athleticism and those things
and so
i think for them they may be fascinated
by their potential
i would say that justin fields to me has
a higher ceiling
bigger faster stronger more dynamic
um we've seen him play big time
competition in the big ten
no slightly what byu has been able to
face but it's different and so for me
i'm willing to gamble on justin fields
over zach wilson
even though i think zach wilson will be
the second quarterback to come off the
board so you think arthur smith snaps
uh justin fields up a kid who went from
georgia to the ohio state
because they went with jacob frohm
instead um
so do you think uh the falcons jump on
him
at four i think it would make a lot of
sense if they did because i think if you
get him i know it's a hometown hero
he's playing right there in atlanta he's
from georgia it would make a lot of
sense
to me also when you think about the way
arthur constructed the offense for ryan
tannehill
a mobile athletic quarterback who was
able to really
add to the running game by being able to
boot out the back door and throw play
passes which are really easy
for quarterbacks because it really
creates huge separation and open window
i think that will work um and also
because matt ryan is there
there's not a rush to get him on the
field and i know we sit here and say
that every year guys aren't going to
play whatever you see these young guys
get on the field
but i think in that situation he would
be the perfect
uh mentor in terms of matt ryan it would
give them a natural bridge to the next
era
so yes i think justin fields would be
the right pitch with them at number four
a few more minutes left with bucky
brooks here on the rich eisen show who
are we not talking about because we're
so focused on the quarterbacks
in this draft who's who's a gem who's so
special that we are not talking about
in this current draft class bucky uh i'm
a fan of the big ten and i'm gonna talk
about micah parsons
the linebacker from penn state in a
normal year
we'll be talking about him and what he
brings to the table
dynamic playmaker on the second level we
saw the impact that devin white
had on the tampa bay buccaneers defense
i think michael parsons is a unique
defender he can hit he can run he can
cover he can give you the nastiness that
you want to see
i think he is someone that for whatever
reason is being undervalued in the
process
i think when we look back at the end of
next season we're going to say
man how did we miss out on michael
parsons he's a dominant player
and we just didn't talk about him enough
partially because he didn't play his
final season after opting out dude
so who who jumps on him who do you think
is he top 10
when it's all said and done uh i think
he should be top 10 i would keep an
eye on detroit i would also keep an eye
on if the new england patriots don't
make a move at quarterback
and he's somehow in range he is to me a
patriot because of his versatility
his toughness and what i believe the
patriots want to get back to
yeah bill does like big ten guys as you
know um
so uh lastly uh bucky i'll ask you
uh what do you think about the general
sense that um
herbert's better than tua will always be
better than tua and the uh
dolphins screwed that one up much to the
chargers delight
what do you think about that knee jerk
year one reaction potentially or is it
knee jerk what do you think of that i
think it's very much a knee jerk
reaction as much as
um i like what fitzpatrick was able to
do i think the reason why the dolphins
wanted
to at the time is because two of us are
going to take care of the football we
know that
turnover margin is the number one
deciding factor in who and wins and
loses games
to a ton of our lord is going to be
outstanding in this league
i think what we have to remember is look
at the weapons that were on the outside
and i know fitz has some success doing
it but he's an
off the cuff unscripted playmaker
when you have two are surrounded by
weapons on the outside which they will
upgrade and free agency in the draft
you're going to see a pass first point
guard who distributes the rock
and so when he distributes the rock and
let the weapons eat
you're going to see a very efficient
offense from the dolphin and i think you
will see them score points
and he will remind us very quickly oh
this is the tank for two uh
scenario this is why we had that
conversation i think people really
jumped off the bandwagon
i think they'll jump back on after
watching them perform in 2021 okay and
who do you think the bears last one for
you i could talk to you all day who do
you think the bears should get at
quarterback again desean watson
if he becomes available and that's why
the texans the texans could literally
make the harsh make everyone blush when
they look at the herschel walker trade
you know what i'm saying like
they could they could pull this thing
off um because there's so many people
that would be so desperate for it i
don't know if the bears have the capital
for that anyway
what do you think the bears knowing
their front office situation knowing the
coaching situation
what do you think they're going to do on
all the pieces like bucky well i mean i
think they're certainly going to be
serious players for
russell ross i think they want to go all
in and try and figure out a way to get
it done
if for whatever reason they're not able
to get russell done in chicago i think
the next guy to cast your eyes on would
be andy dalton
amy dalton played under the offensive
coordinator bill laser
because they're on a one-and-done
scenario where they have to win
i don't think they can wait on a young
guy i would expect
andy dawn to be in play if they can't
pull the trigger on russell west
bucky thanks for the call let's do this
a little bit more often truly appreciate
it
thank you i appreciate it rich you got
it at buckybrooks on twitter
um at big play football on instagram i
follow him you should too
he and daniel jeremiah at move the
sticks podcast
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here